they were trying to accept the news that
he'd been arrested now they'll have to
come to terms with the reality that he's
never coming
back detained on Sunday Israel's prison
service announced that Arafat hamdan
died in its
custody I have Israeli medical
reports yaser says he told the soldiers
his son was
sick when you know that someone is sick
do you arrest him him interrogate him
for 3 Days deprive him from using
electricity food and water what do you
expect to happen to him two Palestinians
died in Israeli custody in less than 24
hours the Palestinian prisoners society
says prisoners have not been allowed any
medical assistance hamdan was detained
here in AER military prison the same
prison abdurahman haer was released from
a week ago he says that conditions were
bad before the Hamas attack now they're
worse we would hear screams from other
cells and smell tear gas but we couldn't
tell what was happening some prisoners
would tell us about beatings by Israeli
forces their hands were broken and heads
and backs were
injured Jaffer did not spend jail time
the bruises on his face tell the story
of several hours of Israeli
interrogation they didn't stop beating
us they hit me here with the butt of the
rifle then here this and punches to my
head the Palestinian prisoners are not
allowed visitors their access to lawyers
has been limited human rights
organizations warn that Israel is taking
revenge against
prisoners as the number of Palestinians
detained by Israeli forces increases so
too does the turnout of families at
Sittin like this one families here know
so little about the status of prisoners
and the little they know makes their
worries
increase the warrior of hamdan's family
is over now They Mourn a son a husband
and a
father men gathered to
pray for strength and patience living
under Israel's occupation many tell us
this patience is being tested
every day nid ibraim Al jaaz the
occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer